let's make a plot of real GDP as a
function of time so this axis right over
here is going to be real GDP so it's an
actual measure not just nominal GDP it's
an actual measure of the goods and
services produced by an economy or the
productivity of an economy and over here
let's have time now in our little
country or whatever economy we're
studying here let's assume that over
time its population is growing so let me
write these things down so population
population is growing over time the pot
and this is not an unrealistic
assumption this is true of most
countries population is growing over
time and also let's assume that
productivity is improving productivity
productivity and productivity is just
essentially how much can each individual
person produce productivity productivity
is going up and productivity goes up due
to technology in fact probably mainly
technology technology mainly technology
but there could be discoveries of
resources discovery of resources or it
could be new business processes and
people would even consider that maybe
technology so new new processes so on a
per person basis they're able to produce
more and more overtime so because of
these trends and these are trends that
do take place over long periods of time
in many many economies you would expect
the real productivity of that economy to
increase so if you were just do the long
term trend just based on these two
things the population growing in
productivity improving over time real
GDP should have a trend something like
that and that is the long term trend of
most properly functioning economies but
when you look at it on the short-term it
doesn't look like a nice smooth trend
line like this when you study any major
economy they're all really any economy
any normal economy instead of just going
this nice smooth trend line it tends to
look something more like this real GDP
real GDP will be going really fast maybe
it higher than the trend line and then
all of a sudden it will it will
essentially recede or
essentially shrink and then it'll start
growing again maybe go above the trend
line then oversee go below the trend
line then go above the trend line it'll
just keep fluctuating it'll keep
fluctuating around a trendline like that
and this fluctuation around this trend
line this is called the business cycle
this right over here and you could maybe
call one cycle you could say it's from
one peak to one peak or one trough to
one trough or whatnot whatever you want
to call it it's this idea that that the
economy isn't just a nice steady
you know steady as you go growth you
have periods of fast growth going above
maybe the trend line and then it recedes
then it expands then it recedes and so
this is the business cycle business
cycle and the term cycle is a little bit
misleading whenever you do think of a
cycle and even the way I drew it it kind
of looks like a nice well-defined
pattern and you know every every the
same amount of years you're going up and
down
it kind of implies that it's predictable
but the reality is that the business
cycle is very unpredictable and
economists more than anyone have trouble
predicting the business cycle so when
you think of a cyclist not this well you
know it's not this nice sinusoidal it's
something much much more unpredictable
so it does fluctuate up and down above a
trend but it's hard to predict hard to
predict and in general you don't have
the same period of time between every
peak in every trough and that's why it
is so hard to predict and we end there
that there are different terms for
different phases of the business cycle
and I kind of used it just in describing
what was happening over here where the
economy is growing so the economy is
growing from there to there from there
to there we would call this phase of the
business cycle
so I'll highlighted that in green we
would call that expansion because the
economy is literally expanding there's
more goods and services being produced
in that economy and then when and we'll
talk about the reasons why this is
happening and then all of a sudden when
it starts to shrink the economy starts
to shrink this right over here or you
could call it recedes you know if you
think of it in kind of a title analogy
this right over here is called a
recession this right over here is a so
that purple part right over there
is a recession and if a recession is bad
enough and is sometimes categorized as a
depression and there's different
categories for a depression there's the
famous joke when your neighbor loses
you're his job it's a recession when you
lose your job it is a depression but the
interesting thing is is we see this
pattern happening every you know whether
it's every eight years seven years every
ten years but we don't fully understand
exactly why it's happening and what
we're going to try to attempt to do in
the next few videos is look at models
that do attempt to explain it and that's
actually the whole purpose why we're
going to study aggregate demand and
aggregate supply now with that said I
want you to view those models with a
huge grain of salt because those are I
would argue overly simplified economic
models that don't take into
consideration probably the most
important factor in the economic cycle
or any type of market cycle and that is
human emotions human human emotions you
might notice in most of our studies of
economics so far we haven't really
talked a lot about human emotions or
humans tendencies to extrapolate the
recent past or humans greed or risk of
rigged fear and greed and all of these
things that are very real things because
in traditional economics they don't fit
neatly into the models and there are
there are new fields in behavioral
economics and behavioral finance that do
try to take into account things like
human emotions but it's not going to
make its way into the models that we're
going to study for in aggregate so an
aggregate supply and aggregate demand
and the reason why I say human emotions
is because that you know just based on I
spent oh I think was six or seven years
in in market so I was an analyst at an
investment firm it was very clear to me
that what drove market cycles and
economic cycles to a large degree was
based on human emotions that what you
have happening over here is that the
further the more the longer time and
this is once again this isn't kind of
what you would classically learn in your
freshman economics class I'm just going
to say this before we start studying the
classical one because I think this does
give a better sense of what's probably
happening in an economic cycle right
over here when the expansion's
phase is starting people are still
skeptical they've just been through this
this you know people were getting laid
off over here people were losing their
jobs people were having
trouble paying the bills companies were
had very low profits or maybe no profits
at all bankruptcies were occurring so
even though the economy is starting to
expand right over here people are kind
of skeptical in the recent past they
remember all of this pain so they don't
want to go out there and start spending
money they don't want to go out there
and start investing but the further and
further they go from that point an
Islamic just explained kind of the
emotional aspect of the economic cycle
which i think is probably the most
powerful one
the further and further they go away
from they say hey maybe this is for real
maybe this is really happening and their
memories of that pain are more and more
distant their memories of all the risks
the memories of all the layoffs and the
bankruptcies become more and more
distant and then they become more and
more confident and more and more eager
to invest and so they start investing
and spending more and more they start
hiring the and and because of all of
that they see fewer and fewer
bankruptcies fewer and fewer layoffs
hiring is starting to occur people get
more and more and more optimistic and so
the economy keeps growing and when you
go to points right around here it's been
a long time since anyone really talked
about major layoffs and bankruptcies and
people you know and and foreclosures and
all the rest and so people over here are
feeling super super confident and
they're probably under playing risk at
this point and they're investing money
they're spending money like there's no
tomorrow because they think there'll
always be good growth they're
essentially extrapolating the recent
past and so they think and there's
actually even been studies that show
that even economists when you ask them
at this point what's the the foreseeable
future going to look like they tend to
extrapolate the recent past so say the
recent past we were growing like that so
in the future we will grow like that but
at this point essentially people are
being too bullish they're being too too
optimistic and they're probably miss
allocating investment and then as soon
as things things don't grow as people
expect they start getting a little bit
fearful but they're still in denial at
this point they get a little bit more
fearful but here they say oh my god
something is going on they start
panicking they all start happening
economy recedes and then we get but we
have the entire cycle again and to kind
of understand this emotional aspect of
it this is something i redrew i redrew a
graph that always gets that always gets
kind of a chain mailed around or sent
around during the usually at during
every bubble when people start becoming
Scott
tickle of the growth and economy and it
traditionally refers to stock market
cycles but stock market cycles are
closely linked to actual economic cycles
and I think these words really do
capture the emotional sentiment of
what's going on in either during the
business cycle or during a stock market
cycle is that right when we're you know
in the mist in the middle of an
expansion people are feeling pretty
optimistic a little bit further into it
people are feeling excitement they're
saying hey maybe this is kind of a new
type of thing maybe we're going to be
able to grow forever then there's a
thrill there people just the last few
years all they do is they remember
making money they say well I'm going to
put all my money in the stock market I'm
going to start buying pets.com and
whatever else and then there's euphoria
there's like wow easy money I don't have
to work for a living I can just keep
flipping houses or buying stocks of
pets.com or whatever else day trading
and then all of a sudden you have some
signs that maybe there was some bad
investment that people's investments
weren't turning out as good as they
expected people get a little anxious
anxious but then as you still proceed
this they start denying it they say you
know some people say is this are we in a
recession thing no no no we're not in
recession it's been so long since we're
in recession things are different this
time the internet changes everything
housing never goes down but then as it
continues as a recession really does
continue they start to get fearful they
start say wait maybe this is something
going on
then desperate then panic and that's
when people really if you think of a
stock market cycle really start to sell
in the case of a regular business cycle
they start to maybe under spend they
start to really hoard things then
capitulation this is when they say ok
things are just bad they're never going
to get any better and then they become
despondent and eventually you could
really say emotionally people start
getting depressed because they say well
it's been so long since we felt all of
these good emotions right over here and
as many good investors will tell you
this is the best time to invest this is
the worst time to invest but then
there's been so long even though there's
maybe a little bit of growth right over
here it's been so long since we
experienced all of these emotions people
are depressed but then as the growth
continues they start to feel hopeful a
little relieved they say hey at least
we're not getting worse and worse and
then you get back to optimism again so
keep this in mind because in my mind the
emotions really are the main factor that
are playing in either stock market
cycles or economic cycles but when we
study it kind of
basically in an economics class we're
going to take a take human emotions a
bit out of the picture which is a little
bit artificial because they might be the
most important part of the picture